barring your audition for on the horizon
not not necessarily referring to that
one but maybe you can bring that in when
you do a Skype audition and you're doing
a read and maybe there's someone on the
other end reading with you maybe not
what do you like about it what works for
you what doesn't work I mean it
definitely presents its challenges for
sure you know a big thing with
auditioning is being to connect with the
reader connecting with the reader
via medium like a computer is a little
more challenging I mean there's certain
things that you can't that you can't
utilize that you would in the room so
your physicality say proximity those
sorts of things really don't come into
play as much in in the Skype format
however that being said there is
something sort of freeing about doing it
within a space that you're comfortable
in and and and sort of having the
detachment from the room as it were
because a lot of actors get intimidated
by the room and rightfully so the room
can be very intimidating in this case
the room being virtual it was sort of a
safe haven for me so but here he is
going you know you know she's really
she's really really pushed you she's
really gotten you past that point you
know she's really this and I'm sitting
there screaming at a webcam just
screaming just full of spittle coming
out my mouth the whole thing and and
he's yelling on me - push it push it
push it and Here I am and and funny
enough a neighbor actually came to me
after that and said everything okay
and I just said well I'm an actor that
explained everything but I think that's
the best way if you can make it yes kite
or via webcam imagine what you're gonna
do in real person with you know when
you're gonna be in that moment so I
think that's a way better test if you
can kill it your webcam or even the
video submission without a reader or
something and you kill it then you're
gonna be amazing when it's gonna be time
to do it live well I think did you have
someone read with you before and then
pasco you did a second one and you had
things to bring to it yeah exactly did
you pick someone and for me didn't
really work I was just like laughs I
hired someone
real wasted money on this geez so but
yeah it really didn't she's very
personal but yeah it didn't have this
angry vibe that I was looking for so
that's why I was like let's do it live
just to an hour so we did it four or
five times live and I can for me it was
to see him reacting to what I was saying
and to push him to push him but then he
you were not afraid I think you were and
the more we were doing it he was jumping
on it took me hours to calm now maybe
she wasn't Alyssa
maybe she was great but she'd I know
that there were specific things within
the relationship and we won't give them
away in this interview but that were
definitely pushing one another's buttons
so you knew who Alyssa was a surgery and
those specific things no I understand
you know the reader did the best with
the knowledge about the story so Fran I
think it's just easier if I'm doing it
but she just read a little more
melancholy she was a little more down
energy where Alyssa is more of a fighter
that was something that we had to
address and that's what we did via Skype
was just missing the storm a little bit
yeah right okay so you've stirred up the
storm I was in yeah and so what what did
you see in his Skype audition that
worked and then maybe you said you had
to keep refocusing him or something yeah
yeah because in the beginning of what
you were just like you said you were
down he was just when you watch this
scene in the film is all over the place
screaming and everything and framing was
five I was playing the loss and the
whole thing almost like an attempt
leading and the yeah and that sort of
thing and and it was because I hadn't
yet been known to figure out Casey yes
no you can read their whole thing and I
was still at this point of yeah figuring
out who he was and I didn't and I didn't
realized the fact that he had inherent
in him and I saw him as being more a
victim of of Alyssa's
behavior as opposed to an active
participant in his own situation
you